salut tout le monde on continue la
préparation à la draft NBA 2023 avec nos
portraits de joueurs nos profils en 20
minutes top chrono l'essentiel sur un
des prospects candidats la draft et sur
ce podcast ça sera Grey
[Musique]
Dick 20 novembre 2003 date de naissance
1m99 100 chaussures mesurées au récent
MBA combine 93 kg de mètres 6
d'envergure il jouait à Kansas cette
saison il a fait une seule et unique
années avant de se présenter à la draft
nous l'avons dixième sur notre big board
même si il va sans doute être actualisé
on enregistre le 14 juin 10ème chez
envergure le 14 juin 10ème aussi chez
ispn donc quand on dit big board c'est
le meilleur les meilleurs joueurs
disponibles ils appellent ça y espienne
best of il est 12e chez the Ringer et
pareil chez the athlétic pour en parler
Hugues et Thomas bonjour messieurs salut
à tous bonjour à tous
énormément d'entrain dans sa voix et
donc il va pouvoir
il va pouvoir nous faire la biographie
le parcours qui qui est qui est Grady
Dick c'est à toi mon écoute c'est déjà
un nom exceptionnel je sais pas s'il a
eu une enfance facile ou pas j'espère
qu'il a été grand assez rapidement parce
qu'on avait quand même bien bien le
charrier là-dessus c'est un coup de
c'est un petit blondinet qui vient du
Kansas donc on est vraiment sur sur le
stéréotype qui a fait son du coup son
lycée donc dans lequel ça ça fait deux
premières années avant de rejoindre la
très célèbre et là tout de suite j'ai un
trou Thomas backup vite fait merci
Thomas voilà la sonorité donc deux ans
là-bas il est convoité par des des i
majord dès les premières années donc
baylord qui est se positionne dessus
Kenza ce qui se positionne dessus quand
il va du coup ça noise à ce moment là
devient un consensus 5 étoiles pour tout
le monde il était dans le top 20 ispn
dans le tome fin 247 portes etc il
choisit de rester à la maison à kenzas
Kenza ce qui est une équipe qui venait
juste d'être championne avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de départ donc il y avait
vraiment de la place pour lui on va en
parler un petit peu après et puis au
niveau de la famille il a une maman qui
a joué à l'université à iOS date si
j'étais pas de bêtises si c'est Iowa les
fans
tomberont dessus mais je pense que c'est
iOS state et avant ça il avait fait un
passage un peu anecdotique mais qu'il
faut quand même être marqué dans le U18
trois fois trois où il est médaillé d'or
au championnat du monde voilà
voilà pour le pedigree du monsieur du
côté de son rôle cette année à Kansas
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu peux nous en
dire et puis peut-être vu que toi tu es
tu es assez calé sur ce qui se passe
avant la NCA est-ce que ce rôle était
différent de ce qu'il a connu avant
c'est à dire à Sunrise notamment
juste avant la NCA alors cette année
premièrement donc il jouait comme l'a
dit Hugues dans une très forte équipe de
Kansas équipe qui avait un gros 5 majeur
établi avec un meneur des genres un
pivot small un pivot small donc qui
faisait que 2 mètres cage chez adan
beaucoup d'ailleurs et une triplette des
lits de chez Hélène Wilson crée des Dick
Kevin mccolar un peu interchangeable
trois gens qui jouent énormément tous
plus de 30 minutes par match donc je
vois déjà 33 minutes cette saison donc
gros
grosse présence pour lui en attaque il
était échoué principalement au repos on
va revenir par la suite sur ses qualités
mais c'est un excellent scooter donc oui
on est 40% de ces tir à 3 points
principalement du catchan shoot même si
il est quand même capable d'en prendre
après mes 80% de s'étirer était assisté
à derrière l'arc donc il jouait pas mal
au football c'est une équipe qui joue
pas mal en mouvement mais c'est de chez
la nourrisson portait beaucoup la balle
pas mal de mouvements donc ça peut lui
permettre de cutopagner ça peut lui
permettre de se libérer à trois points
donc c'est intéressant pour mettre en
valeur ses qualités défensivement vu que
Kevin ma colère se charger
principalement du meilleur genre adverse
mais vu que les trois joueurs faisaient
à peu près la même taille même qui a été
Adam c'est un pander side on a pu voir
un équipe qui pouvait changer pas mal
défensivement donc dit qu'il a pu être
amené à défendre différents profils au
long de l'année et donc voilà
défensivement plus un défenseur
secondaire c'est pas le joueur qui était
envoyé en mission sur le gros porteur de
balle adverse bon c'est un joueur qui a
été intéressant défensivement on en
reparlera et officiellement un rôle
assez peu la balle par terre même s'il
était capable par moment contrairement à
Sunrise où c'était l'une des plus
grosses l'un des plus grosses gens du
pays tout simplement ils mettaient 18
fois
un peu plus la balle mais pas non plus
énormément Sunrise équipe il avait quoi
il avait du personnel à côté lui pour le
faire jouer notamment dans son année
junior peut-être qu'il y a des Chandler
qui portait énormément la balle donc on
a un joueur qui a toujours quand même
plus ou moins été dans ce rôle même si
portait naturellement au vu de son
niveau un peu plus la balle on a high
school que cette année
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je l'ai dit en introduction
il est vu
assez consensuellement quand même dans
un top 12 10 12 de cette draft
quelle est sa grande qualité pourquoi
pourquoi on le draft même si toi tu l'as
un peu plus bas à titre personnel me
semble-t-il
non non il
a une arme principale c'est le tir
extérieur c'est 50 % de 7/3 sont pris au
périmètre avec un énorme volume il a
plus de 40% de réussite sur cette tir là
majoritairement des tiers qui sont pris
en catch and shoot 80% des tirs qui sont
pris en 4G donc il y a quand même
capacité de pouvoir feinter et de poser
la balle mais ce qu'on va lui demander
principalement NBA vraiment c'est
d'écarter le jeu dans les les
stéréotypes que sont devenus les Mac
d'armottes les
duncano Robinson ce genre de profils là
tout en ayant une intelligence de jeu
mais son son atout principal c'est le
c'est le tir et puis pas n'importe quel
il a pas que le catch and shoot je suis
les deux pieds dans le béton et
j'attends que la balle elle arrive très
bon pour pouvoir se déplacer of ball
très bon pour pouvoir réacès avec une
distance largement NBA on va avoir un
joueur qui pourrait prendre les tirs à 4
points s'il y avait encore la Ice Cube
League là et puis un joueur qui
déclenche très vite c'est une capacité
d'exécution très rapide un tiers qui qui
part vraiment qui parle vraiment vite
très difficile à défendre et comme il
est capable vraiment de de tourner
autour des écrans et de bien naviguer on
il s'offre plusieurs options donc c'est
même si c'est pas un énorme athlète il
réussira dans n'importe quelle situation
à être une assez extérieure voir sur sa
chatte charts euh on est autour du Boves
de break dans le périmètre donc hors
corner on est à 40 % du côté gauche 46%
dans l'axe et 53% du côté droit donc
quand la balle arrive sur sa main faible
ce qui est vraiment top tir élite au
niveau une sieste je regardais un petit
peu dans le dans le parcours dans la
division une et surtout dans les i
majors
ce que ça donnait il est dans le top 10
en termes de pourcentage
des tirs à trois points avec un des plus
haut volumes voilà ça reste un pose
quand même le le niveau du garçon
surtout pour un joueur aussi jeune
première année
c'est ça c'est ça parce que c'est un
premier année et alors même s'il est pas
dans les plus jeunes de sa classe c'est
en 2003 mais il est quand même de fin
et effectivement si on regarde ces
matchs suivant la qualité de l'opposant
les statistiques restent similaires et
il a vraiment assez peu de variances que
que l'opposant soit un peu tout pourri
ou qui soit une top 50 équipe de NCS
cette année donc c'est assez
c'est assez marquant de voir ça
Thomas est-ce que tu vois d'autres
qualités supplémentaires qui pourraient
l'installer dans un rôle en NBA oui
clairement comme l'a dit Hugues
principalement c'est son shoot pour
lequel il est plébiscités en loterie
même en top 10 c'est surtout un shooter
déjà de longue durée en Ice Cube de
l'envoyer déjà sévère sur des sur des
volumes et aucun sens mais c'est
vraiment un chanteur de longue durée
reconnue et qui est vraiment très très
fiable derrière gros volume grosses
réussit donc c'est vraiment du top top
shooter lancer franc aussi plus de 85%
et en plus d'avoir un excellent bras moi
ce que je souligne chez lui ce qui est
que c'est un vrai vrai bon genre de
basket c'est un joueur très intelligent
des deux côtés du terrain malgré
quelques limitations qui peuvent avoir
offensivement que ce soit athlétiquement
ou surtout dans son dribble je trouve
c'est un joueur qui fait très bien
bouger la balle qui se déplace sans
ballon qui est capable d'attaquer du
closes et qu'il va pouvoir progresser là
dessus en continuant d'améliorer son RIB
défensivement pareil sachant intelligent
beau il y a très rapidement compris et
les rotations et c'est ce qui va
permettre de 33 minutes ensuite aussi
compétitif que quand ça cette année
c'est qui sait comment défendre il
comprend les rotations il est concentré
il va au charbon au rebond offensivement
défensivement il suit serment qu'on
était à trois points il est vraiment
capable de très bon play il peut se
entrer une pour aller chercher la balle
il y a pas de souci il va prendre des
charges donc c'est vraiment en plus
d'être un shooter c'est un genre très
intelligent c'est un soldat et c'est
pour ça que je l'aime énormément
personnellement car elle est même pas
juste ce tir mais la porte ce vrai
joueur de basket intelligent et très
compétitif
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
développerais chez lui qu'est-ce qui lui
manque peut-être pour toi pour le mettre
à ce niveau là puisque c'est un peu ça
la question toi tu l'as autour de la
vingtième place dans ton big board
qu'est-ce qui manque selon toi et
qu'est-ce qui est-ce que c'est
travailable
déjà je l'ai vers la 20e place je sais
qu'il va faire une très bonne carrière
c'est juste que pour moi il va manquer
de potentialité ce qui va manquer c'est
un physique alors il est très très jeune
c'est sûr il a une bonne taille mais
athlétiquement parlant en termes de
puissance
je vois beaucoup de retard je vois un
joueur qui pour le moment n'a pas très
bien terminé au panier qui a pas
vraiment réussi
à 61% panier ce qui est pas ridicule du
tout non non c'est ce qui est pas ce qui
est pas ridicule mais sur des paniers
quand même qui était assez régulièrement
très ouvert pour lui vu qu'il était
chassé à l'extérieur et puis on a vu un
joueur alors c'est normal encore une
fois il est il est assez jeune mais
lorsqu'il était vraiment défendu charbon
ou collé et on switcher sur lui et on
lui mettait de l'impact je pense à la
marche Mendes face à eux comme ça le
travail qu'à fantony black dessus qui
est un vrai bon défenseur freshmani
black attendu aussi loterie cette année
on a vu les limitations de the Dick donc
géant loterie des joueurs qui pourront
peut-être faire passer un cap à leur
équipe qui pourrait peut-être être une
des deux trois meilleurs options pour
moi diddick va être un rôle player plus
plus dans sa carrière mais le le manque
au-delà du dribble le manque vraiment de
puissance et le fait que je pense qu'on
va très vite pouvoir ne voir que du tir
extérieur chez lui on attaque et pas de
capacité à attaquer un close-up pas de
capacité à pouvoir terminer ça après
capacité à pouvoir cut et finir ce que
question bonne par exemple qui vient
comme ça mais qui avait deux ans de plus
NCA à excellente fait avec Denver dans
un système très léché a pu montrer donc
voilà moi c'est la lettre su que j'irai
développer surtout le tiers il tirage
j'aimerais voir un peu comme ce que
dunken Robinson ce qu'on a critiqué
pendant le canon Robinson pendant
quelques années est-ce qu'il peut
apporter plus que du tir extérieur et ce
qui peut vraiment être une menace dans
le dans le cut loin du ballon dans la
finition au panier
est-ce que la différence va pas se faire
Thomas sur ses capacités défensives et
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on a en dire
défensivement comme je l'ai dit c'est un
joueur très intelligent qui comprend les
rotations qui qui va au charbon qui va
au rebond qui sait faire des plaies au
handball il peut avoir quelques quelques
limitations comme l'a dit HUG il manque
encore de puissance il est pas très
lourd a fait 92 kg pour pour un peu plus
de 2 mètres donc il a encore ce physique
assez fin donc il va devoir continuer de
prendre du poids pour pouvoir mieux
résister à l'impact il peut avoir aussi
quelques limitations de nos mobilités
par séquence il peut se prendre peut se
faire blobay par des gens un peu plus
denses et je trouve qu'il garde de
mobilité d'appui vraiment intéressante
sur laquelle continuait de travailler et
moi j'aime beaucoup vraiment sur
l'intelligence c'est vraiment un joueur
qui va savoir comment apporter peu
importe peu importe ses limitations j'ai
l'impression il était capable de très
bons play même sur du contre j'ai vu des
rotations et monter au compte des deux
mains il a pu vraiment il a pu vraiment
faire des plaies tout simplement
défensivement et je pense qu'il pourra
devenir un défenseur vraiment
intéressant et qui lui permettra d'avoir
la d'avoir la capacité tout simplement
de rester sur le terrain pour pour venir
impacter et pouvoir garder cet impact
offensivement sur de longues séquences
et
d'ailleurs Christiane Brown qui lui
était peut-être un peu plus athlétique
verticalement mais qui va prendre la
même taille que great diddick
Christian Brown est malgré cela était
avait pas des statistiques comme Grey
Didi en fait c'est pour mesurer ça que
que je compare très impressionnante au
contre
Hugues est-ce que c'est de la vraie
intelligence ou est-ce que c'est de
l'intelligence aussi de système on sait
alors il y a beaucoup de critiques sur
la gestion BILS
mais mais le jeu que quand ça se
pratique et quand même généralement
agréable et carré ouais ça c'est un très
beau basket notamment loin du palon avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de mouvements il y
a toujours des écrans des deux côtés
chaque joueur peut à peu près tout faire
aussi en le voyait avec moi avec Benji
etc et puis tu as eu un cap passé par
darwan Harris qui a un petit général de
terrain donc il a eu un système parfait
je pense que si il avait été dans une
équipe avec beaucoup moins de mouvements
peut-être qu'il aurait un peu moins
brillé on se rappelle l'an dernier pas
de Win qui fait le choix de rester pour
son papa dans une conférence minable il
y a l'air donc il a fait un très bon
choix et c'est très intelligent de sa
part d'être allé être allé sur cette
option là et je crois que oui il y a une
intelligence Kenza et le joueur a une
intelligence aussi pourquoi être ses
propres limitations notamment défensive
où il a beaucoup triché il a beaucoup
cherché d'interception Ball en main il a
des je crois qu'il a une virgule cinq
styles par match c'est qui sait très
bien que défensivement en individuel il
va pas pouvoir tenir son duel sur des
petits quand on le force à switcher donc
il va très vite essayer d'anticiper la
ligne de passe il va très vite essayer
d'être agressif sur la main au niveau de
la remontée de balle ou en début de
système parce que derrière il n'a pas
les capacités pour pouvoir défendre en
périmètre
donc ça montre que le joueur il est
quand même très pragmatique sur son
niveau et qui réussit à se cacher dans
un dans un dans une conférence assez
assez compétitive à avoir en NBA où
est-ce qu'il tombe toujours la question
du contexte et est-ce qu'on peut arriver
à dissimuler ses faiblesses et le
favoriser ce que Miami il fait très bien
ou ce que tu es 9h fait très bien ou
est-ce que de plein d'autres équipes le
font très bien ou est-ce qu'on est dans
une équipe
peut-être un peu plus en difficulté
c'est pour ça que j'avais peur au moins
dans une dans une loterie avec un
système un peu moins développé et là on
l'expose on le met un petit peu en
galère après sur ce genre de de profil
là tu attends quelque chose sur trois
quatre ans notamment pour de la prise
physique donc on va être on va être
patient et il y a déjà des il y a déjà
des bonnes bases dans la tête donc après
il y a plus qu'à développer le corps
Thomas l'année prochaine quel rôle il
peut avoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
objectivement même si jamais vraiment
objectif mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
espérer de great Didi que l'année
prochaine pour sa première année NBA et
justement comme il disait sous trois
quatre ans pour toi quel est le le
plafond le meilleur scénario alors
l'année prochaine moi personnellement je
pense qu'il peut jouer mine de rien
assez vite vu que malgré ces limitations
athlétique notamment de mars déjà je
trouve Hugues assez dur défensivement je
trouve qu'il a vraiment de bonne
séquences même sur l'homme je trouve
qu'il manque un corps de régularité et
je trouve qu'il a vraiment la capacité
et c'est également un athlète assez
sous-estimé on n'est pas sur du tout sur
du 21 Robinson et bien plus athlétique
je regardais je faisais des petites des
petits des petits groupes statistiques
sur les joueurs qui avaient mis de 2
mètres il y avait mis 83 points sur les
10 dernières saisons il y en a que 20
qu'on donne plus de 15 fois il fait
partie de ce groupe donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment bien plus qu'un simple
shooter de la de l'athlétisme tout
simplement c'est un joueur qui a une
détente correct c'est un genre qui bouge
qu'un bon moteur et donc je pense que ça
plus son que tu vis plus ses capacités
défensives si on intelligence je pense
qu'il va pouvoir dépasser certaines
limitations marketing je dis pas que ça
va devenir défenseur accro mais je pense
vraiment qu'il peut tenir ce de ce côté
là du terrain et qu'on va pas non plus
avoir besoin de trop le cacher après
pour l'année prochaine même si peut être
ciblable pour l'instant handball je
pense que ça va combinaison de d'impact
offensif avec un shoot qu'on sait fiable
son sa qualité est intelligence de jeux
de côté du terrain que ce soit
défensivement pour savoir faire des
plaies il va se battre il va savoir
faire bouger la balle donc malgré ces
quelques limitations en défense handball
sur porteur je pense qu'il a vraiment
des capacités vraiment sérieuses pour
pour impacter assez rapidement sur des
minutes
et sur le meilleur scénario dans trois
quatre ans pour moi faut qu'il continue
de donc défensivement qui continue de
développer sa masse continue de de
progresser athlétiquement
continuer également on peut toujours
progresser en défense même dans la
compréhension etc forcément il faut
qu'il améliore son dribble c'est une
grosse mission pour lui je trouve que on
n'est pas du tout sur un joueur
d'isolation je pense pas que ça le sera
un jour mais en fait il va tellement
être défendu proche à trois points faire
ça un shooter incroyable et vu qu'il est
des qualitatives assez correctes mine de
rien je trouve pour aller pour aller
exploser au Cercle bah il aura tellement
tellement cet avantage de défendu proche
que même sans avoir un élite et des
qualités athlétiques incroyables qui va
pouvoir aller au Cercle on a vu de
Robinson bien joué les plaies cette
année en plus avec lui il a énormément
progressé et dit que largement supérieur
d'un tien Robinson athlétiquement donc
il va pouvoir avec ses qualités de
facilitateur de jeu également attaquer
du closer avec ton progressant sur son
dribble pour aller chercher la passe
pour aller finir au cercle plus
facilement vu que son touchés encore un
peu régulier ce manque d'impact physique
peut le troubler par moment mais je
trouve qu'il peut vraiment maximiser ses
qualités de shoot par par une prise de
Haendel pour attaquer du closad et pour
ensuite ouvrir son jeu sur du One Two
threbble jumper sur de l'attaque de
cercle et sur du playmaking qui est
vraiment sous-estimé chez lui je trouve
meilleur temps
au combat sur le Shuttle run notre ami
Dick je te le run c'est quand il s'était
au milieu de la raquette ils doivent
mettre un pied d'un côté un pied de
l'autre et re un pied de l'autre
éphémère
donc il sait être agile Hugues qu'est-ce
que tu peux me dire du mental de de la
personne de la personnalité
de ce que tu as vu chez great Didi
qu'est-ce que c'est plutôt bon signe de
ce que tu disais tout à l'heure déjà de
avoir conscience de ses faiblesses de
s'efforcer déjà un premier bon signe
mais au-delà de ça on interview en
dehors du terrain même ce que tu as pu
voir cette année
ouais moi j'ai pas trop d'inquiétude sur
sur ce côté là c'est un jour qui est
déjà très professionnel on avait regardé
plusieurs interviews lui disait de son
côté que ben il laissait beaucoup de
place à son entourage à son papa pour
pour gérer l'environnement sportif en
tout cas l'environnement professionnel
lui se concentrer sur ses études il se
concentrer sur son basket et derrière il
avait pas énormément de choses à aller
chercher quand les modes d'analyser son
jeu il est très clair sur ses points
forts très clair sur ses faiblesses il
veut pas trop se comparer à des gens ils
disent voilà je vais piocher à gauche
j'ai piocher à droite donc il est déjà
très formaté dans dans ses réponses et
puis sur le terrain c'est un mec qui a
pas du tout de problème d'égo de
problèmes d'orgueil qui a laissé les
autres briller dans un collectif challen
Wilson qui a pu prendre les choses en
main des ronaristes les plus prendre les
choses en main
donc voilà que du signe positif c'est
pas frustré des échecs hein c'est un
shooter de série donc
c'est sympa pas de souci là-dessus on a
quand même vu sur quelques matchs où il
était en fait il a très très bien brillé
en début de saison c'était le freshman
qui avait le plus de points et donc très
encensé il était très confiant et
ensuite on débute un peu plus un peu
plus dans le dur et on n'a pas vu
d'énormes changements je trouve ça
mentalité des chansons de match donc je
trouve ça plutôt plutôt positif on a on
a un jeune garçon professionnel
depuis au moins deux ans dans sa tête en
tout cas en résumé pour pour terminer ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure tu y crois
longue carrière pas forcément
Allen billets ou all stars ou quoi mais
une bonne carrière de role player
pourquoi pas titulaire c'est ça ton
c'est ça ouais bah oui parce que il tire
tellement bien et j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il battent vraiment changé sur son
physique donc ça c'est un mec à 3 4
contrats donc ça a une c'est une très
très grosse valeur chaque année on en
draft assez on a draft et décors et qui
se perde notre rareté des docks alors
qui était un peu plus vieux mais voilà
ce genre de le fil là ça ça s'achète sur
le long terme et à la fin quand on fera
le bilan dans d'ici 15 ans on dira bah
oui oui il a fait du bruit des Dick
absolument il aura sans doute mieux
réussi que certaines personnes choisies
au dessus de lui en tout cas on l'espère
Thomas on y croit à quel point je suis
là
je l'ai 10e il me semble 9 dixième je
trouve que la combinaison d'un style
élite avec son shoot de ses capacités
son intelligence tout simplement sa
capacité à se rendre rôtie sur le
terrain des deux côtés en écartant le
jeu en bougeant son ballon en faisant
bouger le ballon également c'est
vraiment pas sûr très intéressant et en
continuant d'améliorer le dribble comme
on l'a dit il faudrait vraiment ouvrir
son jeu et je trouve qu'il est sous côté
également d'un point de vue athlétique
et je trouve que défensivement il va
pouvoir tenir pour jouer dehors de
séquence donc moi je suis pas beaucoup
je trouve je pense que ça peut venir un
très très bon joueur NBA
ING c'était l'essentiel sur lui le
joueur de Kansas vous pouvez aller voir
sa fiche sur envergure.co et vous pouvez
aller sur Youtube ou sur vos plateformes
d'écoute que ce soit 10 heures Spotify
Google podcast etc
pour réé pour réécouter les autres
profils des joueurs de cette draft NBA
2023 au total il y en aura aller au
moins 20-25 de disponibles bisous tout
le monde